la tienda trajes artesanales está en
oferta las camisas que usualmente se
vendían en 200 pesos ahora se venden en
170 170 y 200 cuál es el porcentaje de
descuento en el precio de las camisas ok
vamos a empezar calculando el descuento
en pesos el descuento en pesos sería 200
menos 170 es decir sería 30 pesos pero
nosotros queremos el descuento en
porcentaje es decir estos 30 pesos
queremos ver cuántos son de 200 pesos
queremos encontrar el valor de esta
fracción 30 entre 200 muy bien déjame
simplificar esta voy a dividir entre 10
el numerador y el denominador y me queda
3 dividido entre 20 y ya que tenemos
esta fracción ahora tenemos que pasarla
a un número con decimales para de ahí
poder ver cuál es el porcentaje entonces
voy a hacer la división 3 entre 20 de
este lado
voy a ponerle 3
punto cero
/ dividido entre 20 a ver 20 no caben 3
en 30 así cabe una vez una por 20 es 20
y aquí hacemos la resta 30 menos 2010
baja este 0 20 cabe cinco veces en 105 x
20 es 100 aquí le ponemos 100 si hacemos
la resta queda 0 y el punto decimal va
aquí entonces 3 entre 20 es igual a 0.15
y ahora esto queremos pasarlo a un
porcentaje y para hacer eso lo que
hacemos es multiplicar por ciento
recorremos este punto decimal dos veces
y nos queda 15 por ciento entonces el
porcentaje de descuento fue 15 por
ciento que es la opción b vamos al
siguiente problema problema 5 aquel
número es igual 2 a la menos 4 esto es
un repaso de las leyes de los exponentes
si tenemos un número elevado a una
potencia negativa 2 a la menos 4
eso es lo mismo que poner uno en el
numerador y dividir entre el número a la
potencia positiva 2 a la 4 y 2 a la 4
simplemente es 2 por 2 x 2 x 2 por 2
bueno 4 12 entonces nos quedaría 1 entre
2 x 2 x 2 por 2 sale 2 por 2 4 por 12 8
por 12 16 entonces esta fracción es
igual a 1 entre 16 que es la opción c
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 6
déjame bajar un poco
problemas 6 cuánto es tres cuartos menos
un sexto esto es una resta de fracciones
y para hacerla tenemos que encontrar un
denominador común y un buen denominador
común es el mínimo común múltiplo de los
dos denominadores aquí son 4 y 6 un buen
denominador común sería 12 me parece
12 ajá 4 por 3 26 6 por 12 12 entonces
vamos a pasar estas fracciones a
fracciones con denominador 12 cómo le
hacemos pues este 4 para pasar a 12 se
multiplicó por 3
entonces el 3 también lo multiplicamos
por 3 vale estas dos fracciones son
iguales
podemos pensar a la de arriba como una
fracción en forma simplificada y a la de
abajo como en esta fracción en forma
simplificada a multiplicar por tres su
numerador y su denominador
vamos a hacerle lo mismo a la de acá
sólo que ahora para pasar de 6 a 12
multiplicamos por 2 de modo que este 1
lo tenemos que multiplicar por 2 sale y
aquí ya simplemente es hacer una resta 9
menos dos nos quedaría 9 doceavos de 12
pizza o lo que sea
9 12 a 2 - 2 12 a 2 que sería igual a 7
712 a vos y esa es la opción c muy bien
vamos a arriba al problema siete
problemas siete voy a subir tantito más
un vendedor en una tienda de ropa les
gustan los problemas de ropa al parecer
bueno gana una comisión de 2 por ciento
en cada venta cuánto se lleva de
comisión por una venta de 300 pesos ok
bueno eso lo voy a hacer primero de la
forma tradicional y luego te cuento otra
forma de resolverlo de la forma
tradicional tenemos que multiplicar 300
por 0.02 esto es sacarle el 2% a 300
vamos a hacer aquí la multiplicación
sería 300 por 0.02 multiplicó por 2 2
por 0 0 2 por 0 es 0 2 por 13 6 y hay
que recorrer ahora el punto decimal 12
lugares 12 lugares
entonces la comisión que se lleva es de
6 pesos esto de acá hay otra forma de
pensar este problema un 2% quiere decir
dos cosas por cada 100 es decir el
vendedor se va a llevar dos pesos por
cada 100 pesos que venda como vendió 300
que es el triple y entonces se lleva 6
vale son dos formas de pensar el
problema pues tú escoge la que te
convenga más para para entenderle esa
ley para resolverlo rápidamente vamos
ahora al problema 8 en el problema 8
dice que algunos estudiantes van a la
escuela 180 de los 365 días del año
ok y nos preguntan aproximadamente qué
parte del año van a la escuela aquí la
palabra clave es aproximadamente
no queremos exactamente este el
porcentaje o sea podríamos encontrar 180
entre 365 y hacer la división como lo
hicimos hace rato 180 dividido entre 365
y encontrar aquí varios decimales
pero aquí simplemente queremos un
aproximado y creo que una buena forma de
aproximar esto es darse cuenta que 360
es el doble de 180 y está muy cerca de
365 entonces esta fracción es aproximada
de irme aproximadamente igual a 180
entre 360 sale y esto de aquí es 50%
50% y eso es la opción b eso está bueno
voy a elegir la opción b y observa que
las otras opciones realmente están muy
lejos de 50% aquí tenemos 18% 75% si
hubiéramos tenido o no se 48% o 52% a lo
mejor si habríamos tenido que hacer más
más decimales de esta división o algo
así pero aquí pues simplemente cambie
este 5 por 10 fue cambiar lo muy poquito
nos quedó 50 por ciento y todos los
demás están muy lejos entonces
seguramente es la opción b vale bueno
vamos ahora con el problema 9 en el
problema 9 nos preguntan por el valor de
2 a las 6 por 2 a la 4
dividido entre 2 a las 5 en total a 6 es
un número bien grande 2 por 2 x 2 por 2
así 6 veces 2 a la 4 también entonces
realizar esta multiplicación base o sea
sería sería hacer muchas cuentas más
bien yo creo que lo que quieren que
hagamos es utilizar las leyes de los
exponentes y cómo le hacemos pues esto
de aquí es igual a en el denominador voy
a dejar el 2 a la 5 para multiplicar en
este 22 exponentes o 2 exponencia ciones
con la misma base simplemente ponemos la
base y sumamos los exponentes 64 sería
10 y ahora aquí estamos dividiendo y
cuando dividimos restamos los exponentes
nos quedaría igual a 2 a las diez menos
cinco y eso de ahí es igual a dos a las
5 2 a las 5 8 no está en las opciones
vamos a tener que multiplicar bueno esto
es igual a 2 por 2 x 2 por 2 por 2 2 por
2 es 4 por 2 es 8 por 12 16 por 12 es 32
entonces la respuesta sería de 32